good afternoon we'll start with opening
statements by the Secretary General the
foreign minister and the higher
representative and then we'll have time
for just a few questions Secretary
General Minister
um
it's great to see you both here at the
NATO headquarters so welcome to both of
you
this is a symbol of our solidarity NATO
and the European Union together standing
with a Ukraine
a year ago President Putin launched his
illegal war against a peaceful neighbor
the facts are cleared for all to see
nobody is attacking Russia Russia is the
aggressor
Ukraine is the victim of aggression
and we are supporting Ukraine's right to
self-defense right which is enshrined in
you and Charter
it is President Putin who started this
Imperial War of Conquest
it is Putin who keeps escalating the war
he thought he could destroy Ukraine and
divide us
but he underestimated determination of
the Ukrainian people to defend their
Homeland
and he underestimated our Unity
one year since he launched the Russian
invasion we see no sign that President
Putin is preparing for peace on the
contrary
as he made clear today he is preparing
for more war
Russia is launching new offensives
mobilizing more troops and reaching out
to North Korea and Iran
we are also increasingly concerned that
China may be planning to provide lethal
support for Russia's War
Putin must not win that would show that
aggression works and force is rewarded
it will be dangerous for our own
security and for the whole world
so we must sustain and step up our
support for Ukraine we must give Ukraine
what they need to win and Prevail as a
sovereign independent nation in Europe
I welcome the recent announcements by
allies on new tanks heavy weaponry and
training for Ukrainian troops it is
urgent to deliver on all these pledges
this has become a grinding War of
Attrition a battle of logistics
and key capabilities much must reach
Ukraine before Russia can seize the
momentum
so foreign
and I discussed the need to ramp up
production and improve our procurement
systems to continue supporting Ukraine
upon Ukraine's request
we have agreed that NATO should assist
Ukraine to develop a procurement system
that is effective transparent and
accountable
we have also agreed today to convene a
meeting of NATO EU and Ukrainian
procurement experts to see what more we
can do together to ensure Ukraine has
the weapons it needs
innate we have been working on ramping
or production for many months NATO sets
the standards for ammunition and
equipment for all allies we have
completed an extraordinary survey of
ammunition stockpiles we met with
defense
industry last fall and continue to
engage with them and we will increase
our targets for ammunition stockpiles
through the NATO defense planning
process
this will also help give defense
industry the long-term demand and
contracts they need to invest and
produce more
NATO has had joint procurement among
allies for many years
I also commend the European Union for
their efforts to incentivize great the
production and NATO is prepared to work
with the EU on this going forward
we have seen
pattern of Russian aggression over many
years Georgia 2008 Crimea and donbos
2014 and the full French invasion last
year
we must make clear that Ukraine's future
is within the euro-atlantic family
when the war ends we need to put in
place long-term arrangements for
Ukraine's security to ensure that Russia
does not continue to chip away at
European security and to break the cycle
of Russian aggression
so NATO will continue to stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes and we
will continue to work closely with the
European Union to support you
let me conclude with this
I regret today's decision by Russia to
suspend its participation in the new
start treaty
over the last years Russia has violated
and walked away from Key Arms Control
agreements
with today's decision on new start the
whole Arms Control architecture has been
dismantled
I strongly encourage Russia to
reconsider its decision and to respect
existing agreements
and with that I give therefore to you
dimitro peace
thank you dear Secretary General we are
yes your high representative dear Joseph
today we held the first high-level
meeting in this new trilateral format
between Ukraine NATO and the European
Union
I think it was helpful I think we all
agreed was helpful it was important to
address most pressing security needs
I enjoyed sitting down in this
trilateral format and though although
this is the first meeting that we held
in this format I already begin to regret
that it will cease to exist when Ukraine
will become members of both NATO and the
EU but between now and then we
agreed to work intensively to answer
three questions
how to train most effectively
how to produce and procure weapons and
ammunition
most effectively
and
how to deliver
all of this to the battlefield in the
most effective matter we have to be
aware of the fact that
since February 2022 Ukraine and its
closest partners are implementing
probably the largest logistical
operation since Second World War
and behind big political decisions and
statements there are millions of issues
that need to be resolved
and the more coordinated we get the
sooner Ukrainian Army will kick off
Russian army from the territory of
Ukraine and the sooner peace in
euro-atlantic space will be restored
this is the reason why we are staying
here today
so on trainings I thanked both the
European Union and allies for
their training programs they're very
efficient and of course I raised the
issue of training of launching trainings
for Ukrainian Pilots
on procurement and on production and
procurement we had a very in-depth
discussion on that time has come for
senior diplomas and officials to get
into some details of production and
procurement to be to build the most
efficient mechanism
and therefore Asians already mentioned
I appreciate that we agreed to establish
a working level contact mechanism focal
points to resolve issues related to
production of armaments and ammunition
and cooperation between and streamline
cooperation between producers
contractors and beneficiaries this is
the triangle where things have to be
smoothed and streamlined and then
everything will begin to work
efficiently the capacity to produce is
there
the capacity to deliver is there
so we need coordination coordination to
deliver and this is what uh what we what
we discussed today I also asked Jens to
um
schedule the next annual industry Forum
that NATO holds as soon as possible to
hold it somewhere in Spring to bring
together all defense Industries
including Ukrainian defense Industries
so that they connect they they meet with
each other and they build synergies and
and cooperation
finally
yes and the last point was production
and
trainings production delivery
delivers yes yes and Logistics and and
we dedicated a lot of time to to
Logistics
the Ukrainian NATO format will keep
working on a regular basis there are
many issues that needs to be explored
and and resolved
we appreciate that the Secretary General
will be working on helping us with
building our net effective National
procurement system
and we will be moving forward with one
goal to
end this war as soon as possible with
the victory of Ukraine which is
unavoidable
thank you thank you dimitro Youssef
please
thank you
let me start
by stressing the historical nature of
this this meeting
the the three of us
standing here today
Ukraine NATO and European Union
standing here today for the first time
in this constellation of three
it's a clear demonstration of our Unity
to continue supporting UK for the
purpose of supporting Ukraine
we have done it since day one
since the first day of the Russia
invasion
against Ukraine the European Union and
NATO have been standing together
not only in condemning not only in the
worst
in the strongest terms the Russia
aggression but
working together in order to provide
Ukraine with the capacity to defend
itself
and today we are reaffirmed the
unwavering support to ukrainians
territorial integrity and its right to
self-defense
our resolve has been stronger from the
beginning and we will continue doing so
and I think that today's discussion has
been crucial to coordinate the key word
that culeba has said to coordinate speed
up and increase our support
it is necessary in order to make the
rule of law Prevail over the rule of the
gun the rule of the force
and it is the only way that Ukraine can
win this war
to speed up to increase to coordinate
better our support
because we are facing a situation where
the war is showing its awful face
with bombing of hospitals starving
entire cities to death
that's what Russia is doing instead of
taking the steps towards a ceasefire
which is something that we are asking
for
remember Russia is a permanent member of
this United Nations security Council
Russia is the nuclear power
and in spite of that he has violated
this Charter invading a peaceful
neighbor
and in line with United Nations Charter
Ukraine has the Sovereign right to
defend itself
against this unfounded aggression
and International Community
we have the right to support it
to support the aggressor is not in
accordance with the United Nations
Charter
to support the aggressed it is perfectly
legitimate
and Ukraine needs all the support
we can provide
starting with weapons and ammunitions
they didn't they need them more than
ever
and we are looking for the ways to
accelerate
the deliveries from member states and to
Ukraine
for that we have a tomb European peace
facility
which has been working
since the beginning which is day one
and altogether member states and
European institution has provided more
than 12 billion worth of weapons and
related supplies to Ukraine
we have been launching
a great training program that will train
about 30
000 Ukrainian Soldiers by the end of the
year
but it's still not enough
we have to accelerate our military
support to Ukraine
today especially ammunition tomorrow
with all that kind of arms
in order to fulfill all your needs
and I think this meeting will provide us
with a better coordination procedures in
order to continue doing that in a United
and efficient manner
thank you okay we'll start with interfax
Ukraine lady in the bank
thank you Anna Ukrainian news agency
interfox Ukraine Irina summer uh
Secretary General what is your
assessment of today's Putin's threat how
serious they are if you allow I will
quote the more long-range weapons the
West gives
the further Russia will be forced to
push that threat away from itself
High represented a question for you
about speeding up a process to deliver
to Ukraine you said yesterday that
decision will be taken by Minister of
Defense next week but Ukraine needs
ammunition today can we expect the
approaches I mean decision taking
process will be speed up and minister
kuleba do you have any information
regarding what Chinese peace plan is
about any details what can we expect
from it do you see possibilities that
China
for from being partner with Russia right
now will become a Ally in this war what
kind of consequences it can lead to
Ukrainian thank you
what you have seen today is that
President Putin is in no way preparing
for peace he's preparing for more war
he's preparing for new offensives and he
is mobilizing more troops and sending in
more weapons and that's exactly why we
need to step up our support for Ukraine
because it will be a tragedy for
ukrainians but it's also dangerous for
all of us if President Putin wins in
Ukraine
um then we have to remember what this is
this is a war of choice this is a war of
aggression uh Russia decides to invade a
neighbor Ukraine and Ukraine of course
has the right to defend itself uh that's
enchanting even shorter and and we uh
NATO allies uh EU members all of us have
the right to provide support to Ukraine
and that's exactly what we are doing
then of course NATO allies we are
providing support to Ukraine
unprecedented support we we step up and
deliver more heavier more advanced
weapons and we have constant
consultations with Ukraine on on
different types of weapons but also on
how to ensure that all the systems all
the weapons which are already there work
as they should because we need to
remember this is not only about
providing new systems but also ensuring
that artillery the armor the air defense
systems which have been delivered
already have the spare parts have the
ammunition have the maintenance have the
fuel they need to function and therefore
this is really a battle of logistics and
that's the reason why I also welcome the
meeting today where we focus on how can
we ensure that we provide all the
supplies and all the support uh Ukraine
needs to to defend itself then
of course NATO also has another task and
that is to prevent this war from
escalating Beyond Ukraine and that's the
reason why we on the morning of the
invasion activated our defense plans and
added the houses or more troops to our
presence in the eastern part of the
Lions backed by a significant Iran Naval
power to send a very clear message to
Moscow that Nate was there to protect
every inch of NATO territory if one
allies attacked it would be regarded as
an attack on the whole Alliance so we
will continue to support Ukraine for as
long as it takes and we'll continue
to provide incredible returns and events
for all NATO territory awesome
thank you well yesterday we had forenga
first council meeting
and we will have a defense misters in in
some days it's the beginning of March is
tomorrow
and then after a jumbo meeting putting
together defense and faringa first
ministers but defense is an issue of the
Ministers of Defense
defense remains competence inside
European union or the member states and
it's up to the defense ministers to take
decisions but we have to prepare these
decisions and we have to act with a
sense of urgency
after listening to my colleagues Foreign
Affairs ministers yesterday immediately
after
yesterday night a sent a letter to all
defense ministers that will be receiving
today
asking them to provide ammunitions to
Ukraine
from their stockpiles
I'm from the contract that they have
already passed with the industry giving
Ukraine priority
because the time parameters of what is
happening and what we have to do is
measure it on weeks not a month
so first thing to do is to use what we
have
second to have more
and to have more we have to procure to
the industry
member states have already done many of
them alone
doing that together is better
and third we had to increase the
industry capacity because today the
rhythm of a
using ammunitions
is greater than the rhythm of production
so you know even even uh if the water
goes quicker that it comes in at the end
it's empty so we have to increase the
three things procurement methods
industrial capacity
and Mobi design quickly the resources
that we already have
this is the purpose of this
strategic coordination
that takes place don't forget it in the
framework
of a demolishing by Russia how the
security system
and today there is a lot of proof of
that
Secretary General mentioned Russia
announcement of
suspending the Stark treaty
is another proof that what Russia is
doing is demolishing the security system
that was built after the end of the Cold
War
so we have to work on the short term
providing ammunition quickly it's a
matter of weeks and we had to start
thinking about which will be the future
security system but by the time being
let's concentrate on the most urgent
issues
yes we had a meeting with the Chinese
top Diplomat or former colleague foreign
minister
uh
Mr Vani he he shared with me key
elements of the Chinese peace plan
we are looking forward to receiving the
tax because this is not something that
you can you know make your conclusions
on just after hearing I'm hearing what
this plan is about you need to get into
every detail so once we receive the
paper we will thoroughly examine it and
come with our own conclusions as you
know president zelenski proposed his
peace formula consisting of 10 steps and
we believe that it's a comprehensive
concise and efficient way forward
so for us peace formula remains or the
invoking peace formula remains atop a
top priority
when it comes to the Chinese position as
such I think there is one element that
is common for Ukraine and China and it's
not just an element it's a Cornerstone
which is the principle of territorial
Integrity so everything China
has been doing and will be doing in the
context of the Russian aggression
against Ukraine if we take the political
rhetorics aside and look at actions
should be aimed at
defending the principle of territorial
Integrity because if any country of the
world helps Russia to destroy
territorial Integrity of Ukraine then
the principle is undermined and the
message is clear anyone else can do that
in any other specific situation on the
global map
on the world map
James Bay is from Al Jazeera um
Secretary General on New Start can you
tell us how worried should we all be
does it make the world a more dangerous
place now
um foreign minister
um you clearly as we approach the
anniversary have a lot of unity in the
Western countries and here in NATO but
what about beyond the Western countries
what about the rest of the world as we
approach a general assembly vote coming
up at the end of the week what's your
message to the rest of the world as we
approach this this first anniversary and
high representative with regard to the
secretary General's comments about being
increasingly concerned about China
you've said that you've had assurances
this weekend at the Munich security
conference from State councilor Wang Yi
that they're not going to send more
weapons have you been shown proof by
NATO or the US that there really is a
problem here thank you
more nuclear weapons and
less orange control makes the world more
dangerous and that's the reason why in
NATO we have worked so hard
to engage Russia on issues related to
Arms Control and why NATO allies have
supported the new start
and also why I'm calling on Russia Today
to reconsider its decision to suspend
its participation in the new start
agreement we have to remember that this
is one of the last major Arms Control
agreements we have
after Russia started to violate the
agreement that banned all the
intermediate range weapons the INF
treaty that led to the demise of that
treaty a few years ago now they are
suspending the other big nuclear arms
control treaty the new start which
regulates limits on the total number of
long-range strategic weapons
so so this is just another example that
we are moving away from uh the arms
control architecture the international
rules-based order we have used decades
to build step by step an agreement by an
agreement so the combination of Russia
violating some of these agreements
leading to the demise of the rnf3t and
then walking away from the new start
makes the world more dangerous and just
highlights the importance of that we
stand together all those countries that
believe in the rules based International
order and blue believes in freedom and
democracy
the message first my message to
everyone asking about the global South I
think the picture that the West stands
by Ukraine and the rest doesn't is
inaccurate
uh if you look at the results of the
latest resolution adopted in uh
October 2022 we got 143 votes
and many countries of the globe of what
is called Global South voted in favor of
that resolution
uh
so the situation in the global South is
nuanced it's not black and white but
you're right more needs to be done to
engage with the global South and I think
that basically this
struggle for gulab for the for for the
for Global South and support of these
countries brought the whole this whole
part of the world back uh
to the to the top of the world world
agenda in terms of big politics not only
in terms of
resources or uh Technical and
humanitarian assistance but in terms of
big
big political political game we have to
continue reaching out to the global
South with a very simple message
that it's not about Ukraine it's about
the rules which also protect you
and if we fail to protect these rules in
Ukraine
then you will find yourself in danger
and that's definitely not something that
you want to face
I think it's very simple and I think
that the more this war lasts the more
understanding there is
yes about about China well I have to
confess that I had a good personal
relation with the state Council of one
year since a long time ago when I was
Minister Foreign
Affairs of China
and we had a Frank conversation in
Munich
and he was very very much clear
I can't repeat his work
the words
that China doesn't provide arms to
countries of War
and he they are not providing arms to
Russia
and they will not provide us to Russia
that's what he told me
stressing clearly that this is the
principle of the following a first
policy of China and by the way asking me
why do you show concern for Me Maybe
providing arm to Russia when you are
providing arms to Ukraine and they had
to explain the the big difference
had to explain what is at stake for us
Europeans in the war in Ukraine
so that's what China told me
and nevertheless we have to remain
Vigilant but as far as I know that is
not evidence that China has been doing
what they claim not to be doing
thank you but going back to to Joint
procurement issues
um Minister kuleba the fact that as uh
Mr Burrell says this is the first time
you're standing here and you've got a
war that's been going on a year
um and and that you're only now revving
up these coordination mechanisms is this
too late for you should this have been
foreseen how desperate is the ammunition
shortfall right now as everybody's top
priority
um and um hi representative Burrell how
fast can you move
um on on the EU side to on this proposal
by the estonians to put 4 billion in a
in a fund and make joint procurement
that way as some people say like you did
with the vaccines to give industry the
security and Secretary General
stoltzenberg
um I've spoken again with industry and
they say again the contracts are not
coming in so I know I asked you this
this last week but it still seems to be
true and I'm told that there is still
this huge gap between what people are
putting on paper what money they're
putting on the table and what is needed
how long would it take now to scale up
this ammunition production Burrell is
saying weeks there's no way is there
well when any war begins the first thing
you do you go into your stocks
and that's what we all did in Ukraine in
nato in EU countries then let's be frank
uh no one expected this war would last
so long
and therefore at certain moment the
situation was reached when uh
it became apparent that production has
to be rolled out and the first time we
started talking about it was actually I
think last last
end of end of summer
and many production lines started to
work in order to produce ammunition
necessary for for you for not only for
Ukraine but also for replenishing the
stockpiles of the allies
but yes not enough has been done and
this is why we're standing here
this is the statement of fact and if you
ask me
on any issue was
enough done right to provide you with
everything you need the answer is no
if I if we had already won the war and I
would be standing here I would have said
the opposite
I would say yes we appreciate everything
was done because we won the war
as long as this is not the case
it's not enough
I do not undermine efforts and personal
leadership of janse and Joseph in
resolving tons of issues
and I'm I'm confident it will be years
after this press conference it will be
very enlightening to read some Memoirs
where the role of each personality in
resolving one issue or another like
tanks air defense and other and other
matters will be will be uh will be
revealed
but this is why we're standing here to
speed up everything that is needed and
you touched upon a very important issue
the connection between the producer who
is ready to produce
and the buyer who is ready to sign a
contract and yes after speaking with
representatives of Defense Industries
this Gap became even more evident
but it doesn't mean that there is no
political will on the side of the buyer
there is
a lack of procedures and understanding
of how it should all work
and this is why we're meeting
with defense Industries this is why
we're setting up the coordination make a
mechanism to bring everyone together we
need we are like you know in the
beginning of the fort Ford company we
have to bring to build a production line
where everything is streamlined where
everything works
to bring back to Europe to bring the
situation back to Europe where
everything works as Swiss watch
that's that's the purpose and yes
unfortunately it requires the
involvement of people like us I wish it
could be done at a technical level but
that's not the case we need to get
involved and we need to get it fixed and
that's what we're doing
well look the time parameters of the
production of
Warfare
material in Europe today
it is still not in accordance with the
urgency
in the front line
it's still not
so it's a matter of speeding up
and it can be done
quickly
because the European peace facility
which is the instrument that we have
been using
has much more flexibility than the
European budget in fact it is not part
of the European budget is if we can say
it's a kind of an intergovernmental Club
where member states can decide among
them
to increase the funding available and
they have already decided
from which ago they decided to top up
the initial amount of money of the
European
this facility with more than 2 000 more
billions so it's a decision that can be
taken without any kind of complex
procedure involving the European
Parliament and changing the European
Union budget because he's not part of
the European Union budget
is an island
managed by the member States among them
so it can be done quickly depending on
the political will of all of us all of
them member states
and that's what we are trying to do
but
to provide the Munitions to Ukraine
through the European peace facility is
nothing new
we have been doing that since the
beginning of the war
asking member stage provide us with the
remunition to be sent to Ukraine and
being co-financed by the fund
so the only thing is to do it quicker at
the larger scale
support the industry to produce they
need contacts and that has been a
message from the industry all the way
and that's also reason why we started to
engage with the industry last fall when
we saw that this war was dragging on and
that was urgent need to ramp up
production because as semester colaba
said in the beginning we were actually
depleting our own stocks but then we saw
that the rate of consumption of
lamination is much higher than the rate
of production and therefore this is not
sustainable therefore need to to produce
more but this is not something we
discovered now it is called it's many
months ago and therefore we have been
engaged with the industry and the
Nations for a long time and contracts
have been signed in United States France
Norway among others but as as Mr colaba
said dimitro said and we need we need to
speed up we need to do more and that's
exactly why we are meeting here to see
how can we mobilize even more how can we
speed of production partly while
coordinating partly by improving the
procedures because big investment
projects takes time there's a lot of
bureaucratic works that has to be done
to ensure accountability transparency
and also effective
contracts so that's exactly why we are
working as NATO with our own agencies
and our own systems and our own arm and
directors while we are working with the
European Union and now in our what we
also then now work with Ukraine directly
and also in this group of three and why
we have decided to convene our experts
to follow up and see what more we can do
to run pop production and and in a more
in in a faster way and also why NATO has
already decided
to assist Ukraine with with
strengthening their capacity to do
procurement so so this is one element of
many steps that we are taking together
to ensure that we have sufficient
ammunition but also weapons to both
replenish our own stockpiles but also to
deliver to Ukraine the last thing is
that we have also of course reached out
to International partners
and and
to see to what extent we also can help
or they can help to provide the
necessary
direct support to Ukraine or at least
replenish our own stocks
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference thank you